[Music]
so good morning everyone English great
pleasure to introduce young gonk who is
a page 20 at UC Berkeley working with
Kaushik's in so Kaushik was actually my
colleague small word react has generally
been interested in program analysis
doing analysis of properties for
checking correctness performance
security and his focus has been on doing
dynamic analysis for JavaScript programs
he has internet MSR microsoft more
broadly two times also internet google
saw the work that he did when he was at
Microsoft actually is has been
integrated as part of Microsoft software
and looking forward to you talk yeah
thank you for the introduction and thank
you everyone for coming instead of going
to the top Francis the CEO and so today
on my talk is about dynamic data
collection diagnostic for improving
JavaScript applications so so this
basically this is it gives an overview
of my research on in the past seven
years how I sew my doing my break
to do my PhD in Berkeley I was mostly
focusing on dynamic analysis for
JavaScript and in Berkeley I was working
with Satoshi working on project
Kwajalein which was initially started in
some research America and it was also
used things and some research America
and based on that project we also
developed a number of research for
dynamic analysis and when I was
interning on the Microsoft Research
I mostly worked with Mark and we don't
working on the a project called a single
track which is also dynamic analysis
free Melissa keeps track of the
interactions between the node.js
applications the underlying operating
system and that aphromoo has been used
in the toggle core engine for time
travel in debugging and it's also being
integrated into Microsoft software of
Connaught glimpse which is a four stack
no G's diagnostic tool and based on that
we firstly extends our framework to be a
sandbox for no GS I based on which we
found about 300 security vulnerabilities
and we ported it to some security
companies and about 120 of the security
policies are consider is the hardest
beer and in my second internship I
actually work with such a core team
working on a memory visualization tool
for
no chuckle core and we also shared the
true with the Netflix engineering team
and before I start my so before my PhD I
was also working on some projects like
applying machine learning techniques to
solve engineering problems so what we
usually call it's the mining software
repository so in my first part of my
talk I'll first the talk about this
challenging project so so before I start
to let me first to give you awesome so
let me first introduce the motivation of
my research so why do we care about
JavaScript so a lot of people still
thought that JavaScript it was still the
toy language it's only limited that they
used in the browser and nowadays
JavaScript has already been increasingly
used to liking back-end server side
development for all those companies like
uber LinkedIn they've held Bank of
America warm and lab tricks you're
starting using node.js to abuse your
server-side applications and for all
those desktop software like we chose to
do code and it's like our orbit on top
of the audience and it's variants and
this is another graph showing the number
of packages for node years comparing to
the number of packages for other
languages as you can see over time so
NPM is essentially broken it so it so he
is essentially exploding and and this is
in other slides showing the download
statistics of NPM packages over time so
right now about every week there are 2
billion downloads of NPM packages so
it's actually growing exponentially and
but unfortunately javascript is the
number of design languages many of you
knows that it's first version was
designed and England leaving nearly 10
days and in such a rush not all these
scientist issues were well thought and
not there are lots of problematic
language features integrated into the
language and using those bad features
you can on it can often leads to bugs
performance issues or even security
loopholes in the language and Java has
to be backward compatible so those
language features are still around and
this is a joke on the internet saying
that on the left hand side there's a
book called JavaScript the definitely
guide I was right hand side there's a
book called jobs with the good parts
and yeah comparing the thickness of
these two books you can quantify the
good parts of the language and their the
rest are what we call the evil parts so
so on one hand you have a language
that's very popular but that has lots of
awful parts so how do you deal with this
issue so um so industry there are a
couple of solutions either you program
your language in so either you write
your programming in other languages and
compile it into Java scripts so this is
what's the typescript is doing or
Google's GWT compiler is doing and
there's another option is that you
provides better to chain support for
Java Script language so so right now
there are a couple of tools that are
widely adopted in industry for
JavaScript development both so all them
are basically link tools like Gia's
hints she has a link to yes linked in
the closure linked i also interned as a
Google Cosima patterns team I personally
also developed a couple of link juice
for closure linked but those tools are
up you are based on static analysis and
most of them are actually based on very
primitive static analysis or what we
should call them syntactic analysis so
this they just check very sync or
syntactic rules on Java screen and try
to find some potential errors things
Java code but the limitation of static
analysis is pretty obvious they are
trying to approximate the wrong time
behavior of a program and because of the
limitations of static analysis like
alias analysis or other things um it's
very hard to do precise static analysis
for JavaScript and because of JavaScript
has lots of dynamic features like
prototype or valleys ah it's even harder
to do static analysis for JavaScript so
and also oftentimes those - Stu - if you
were precision over soundest by
suppressing warnings and so that's the
challenge and we try to alleviate this
kind of problem by using dynamic
analysis and in the past four years I've
been working on about two that I make
analysis free more for JavaScript why
Scott Relangi in otherwise called async
track or knows security platform so like
so like for chalenge he the idea is that
whenever you execute a piece of Java
code Jelani will monitor
the wrong hand events from the Java code
and notify you some basic runtime events
like reading a variable or calling a
function or setting a property of an
object and stuff like that by
overwriting those API sinka get all
sorts of longtime events of Java scripts
and then you compute some kind of
interesting dynamic analysis some
JavaScript while eating track and these
nodes security sandbox focuses more on
the interactions between the JavaScript
code and the underlying operating system
so whenever there is the interaction
between the Java code and the underlying
approaches and the underlying operating
system this Freeman actually notify you
some kind of event like a building
node.js module is being required or a
synchronous system API is being caught
or callbacks is being registered or
Kovacs is being invoked and stuff like
that so I'll introduce the first part
which is challenging so see Jelani is
essentially a source to source transfer
felishj translation framework and so for
example if we have original JavaScript
programs that looks like this which is
science piece value to 8 then the
simplified instruments the code enjoy
rank it looks like this and it's
preserving the original semantics of
Java code which means they were still
signed this value into 8 but
additionally that's two more callbacks
so one called address corresponds to the
reading of variable B another callback
corresponds to the writing of far away
so when you write so we execute this
instrument to the code you will not only
assign this value to a but it will
additionally causes to Kobach functions
yes yes overheads is about 25 to 30
times slowdown but later on I'll show
you a demo and showing that it's
actually a reasonable slowdown forefront
in the webpage so because usually in
front of webpages like javascript is a
single threaded application right and so
as long as piece of jobs would cody
sexism other than like one millisecond
or oh 10 milliseconds then the user can
kind of perceive the slowdown so usually
in the front end the javascript code
function execution is actually less than
like 10 milliseconds and then
when so after instrumentation on these
you can feel the slowdown but it's not
just to slow so later I can show a demo
running on the real world of
applications yeah it's only meant to be
deployed for in-house like browser
testing and havoc wait and I make
analysis not for the production server
side of deployment yeah so so after
overriding since primitives you can do
all sorts of interesting dynamic
analysis and Jelani handles all kinds of
rom-com events in Java scripts like
creating a literal a reading variable
putting field to an object or calling a
function entering branch unary operation
binary operation cetera et cetera and
because the JavaScript EC kind of weird
languages there are lots of weird syntax
semantics and there are a lot of the
corner cases that we learned in a hard
ways so we spend a lot of time working
on the engineering part of this project
to make it work on real-world
applications and so first let me give
you a demo of the Genki so we have
online demo of jalan key and this is so
this webpage gives you a live demo of
what your language like and i can create
the statements they assigned to be on
the on this panel it will likely shows
the instrument the codes right here and
you can even see more dynamic gnosis so
for example here i have a program and
here is the instrument of the program
and over here it shows the Gilani's api
like i can override all kinds of I saw I
was I'm sorry
so I can override all kinds of random
events such as putting field to an
object creating literal by overriding
those functions you can receive all
kinds of runtime variables or values or
events like for example if you have a
binary operation and inside his function
you will receive events such as what's
the type of sub binary operation what's
the left operand what's the right after
open and what's the result and you can
you can either return different results
kind of motive
the behavior of the Johnson program
during the execution and yeah and if
you're wrong he was shows at 39 which is
not a number of generations are usually
corresponds to like a nominee during the
execution he's a job hood program yes
yes how introduced that partly with a
little bit later because we hung dynamic
masks research based on these two and we
are used in to check crack nice tissues
and performance issues in Java code so
for libraries we also instruments that
as well so anything that's running in
the browser we instrument such but we
can also selectively in lots of
instruments that's actually worse this
additional engineering work so so when I
was in Berkeley I also did in other work
is to pour Joong Ki from sea back and to
front-end because johnny was originally
designed for Ronnie on low GS and when
we also want to do dynamic analysis for
jobs please in the front and a web page
as well and but in the front-end the job
distribution model it's a little bit
more complicated and and low G is
because seeing Java scripts in the front
and there are lots of different ways
that you can trigger a piece of jobs
coding a browser because you can like
incorporate a piece of Java code just in
the HTML file or even import a piece of
Java code from the external file or even
dynamically request a piece of
JavaScript goes through the Ajax or even
dynamically generates a piece of Java
code inserted into the back and insert
it back into a web page so we expanded
sweet experiment we saw different kinds
of implementation and we finalized our
prototype to handle all those kinds of
scenarios so our implementation works
like where proxy such ah well monitor
all the network requests are sent out
from my computer and if the response
contains any piece of Java code Sandy
will be intercepted to me and instrument
it so all Java codes before these reach
to the browser they're already
instrumented to buy a chalenge key
give you a front-end demo of what your
lankey looks like so here I'll start my
proxy okay and now I'm going to start
loading a web page that's using WebGL to
show a stunning visual effects of water
in the web page yeah that's right so so
this is web page is fully instrumented I
can show you the source code so for
example if I click on this one as you
can see here all those code are already
instrumented this J dollar two IDs and
stuff like that' or hooks inserted by
Joey and and to answer your question so
as you can see is these two C
instruments web page it looks like and
the slowdown so the soda actually also
depends on the dynamic analysis the
codes that you are going to write for
example here I'm going to instrument all
of the reading variable operations in
the front and a web page so I just
created this callback function Singh
thought reads equals ID which means the
ID of the source location name of the
variable value of the variables there
are other arguments but I just don't
care
so because javis is a dynamic language I
can just ignore them and if I just print
all variable names that are read by Z
web applications and they'll be
extremely slow so I just want to do some
sampling like say every 1000 operations
are just a print the name of xaro's is a
variable that's being read and if I do
that as you can see it's printing is
variable name and I can even replace the
hooks at the wrong time so that you will
have a much higher
sampling rates like every 100 operations
and inns and as you can see here it's
becoming much slower and I can remove
the hoops at wrong time so as you can
see here on stop printing the variable
names and this bump and it is becoming
faster again yes and also for every
variable operations so for every
variable reading operation you are
additionally call a function a callback
function that's also causing some of the
slowdown yeah so so right right
in this example see IO is the bottleneck
yeah so based on this showing he
announced the Fremen we actually the
number of research one of the research
he said we won't use this analysis
framework to dynamically detect some of
the correctness issues in the fronton
webpage so we develop these two core
dealings which is to for dynamically
checking bad coding practices in
javascript so because Java is not well
designed language search a lot of awful
parts in the language and people in
software industry have learned a thing
over time called coding practice which
is so which are essentially set up in
formal rooms that people have learned
over time and if you follow those rules
you can um so you can generally improve
the quality of your software so um so by
better quality I mean fewer bugs or
better performance or better
maintainability or even fewer security
vulnerabilities in your code and to give
you a concrete example of what coding
practice looks like in Java scripts on
so let me ask you to take a look at this
like small chunk of code and think about
what would be the final value of a sum
after executing this simple JavaScript
code
so I've asked this question to all the
people including some of the developer
jobs with the oil press to Google and so
far nobody has given me a hundred
percent correct answer no yeah so Sri is
actually one of the wrong answers that I
got frequently so a lot of people
thought that the falling over AC
reaching over ray elements so the
thoughts of value should be 66 but
unfortunately for ovaries actually is
rating over property names inside an
object so here because we pass in an
array then it's actually each rating
over a rating taxes some people call
these rights but see for cause that
arena axis the property names are of the
type stream so Java super actually
converts the arena access to string
values therefore the final value should
be 0 1 2 that's just a short answer on
another issue he says there are some
cross-browser issues in some earlier
version of some browsers it flowing over
a gray will also each rate over all of
the building system function names in
sites an array objects so like index
also 2 string will also be concatenated
to the final result and even for like
browsers like Firefox or Chrome if you
add additional properties to the
prototype object souter of that array
those additional property names will
also be iterator over and concatenated
to the final string so um so the correct
ways easier use on conventional for loop
or use building functions to either
agree to over array elements so if you
use falling over a it's likely that you
were misunderstands see the outputs or
you will misunderstand the semantics of
the codes and you are likely to
introduce boxing to your code and if
you're collaborating with other people
when they are refactoring our codes they
may also be some send your codes and
they may also introduce box and also
because foing ovaries much is slower
than the following choice so the
conclusion is that avoid using falling
over in javascript whenever possible so
if you want to statically
this kind of bad coding practice is very
hard because you have to determine
whether or not these OBJ's array or not
oh that's generate very hard problem for
JavaScript his geometry is very dynamic
language and type inferences or anti
bringing in currency is also very hard
results the type annotations but in
jalan G it's very easy all you have to
do is such first let's Jelani identify
all of the folding program constructs in
your program and whenever you found the
following over ray are you just rights a
dynamic Nasus to monitor all these
values flowing into this slot and even
this obj a trondheim isn't a raisin
you're doing for you over ray that's in
that case it's still doing voiceover a
right because sometimes it's doing for
new arrays and the result becomes
unpredictable
yeah yo-yo issue a soft warning so we
looked at JavaScript right so so in my
demo right here so Joe Langley provides
a set of API so he can override and one
of the API is a it's actually a for loop
and then you can detects whether or not
on its foreign constructs and if it is
then you can just the check at run time
and see if that operand is actually an
array or not so so so so so far we don't
have a way for you to declare which part
of the program you want to instrument in
which part you're not so answers so
currently what we do is that we just
instruments every basic programming
construct and at the wrong time you can
choose to override these functions or
not so e so each so so at runtime
if you don't arise those functions then
there will be no callback
otherwise the obeah echo back yes that's
definitely one way to like lower down
the overhead of the instrumentation
framework um so in our dealing project
we analyzed the JavaScript language and
we formalized about 28 code smell random
patterns and we run on two hundred
swords most popular websites and we
found about 19 clear about some of the
world's most popular websites so so far
we just randomly loads the pages on
those websites without actually doing
most of more very specifics the advanced
dynamic analysis or testing generation
to like trigger more action scenes web
page patterns there so by random
patterns nice means that's um
it's like if the wrong time events
exists it's like a predicates and what
we should do or why we should check is
something and the monitor is kind of
that you like for instance we have not
for a program JavaScript but internally
ten plus years ago I mean with
declarative language was specification
and you can either check them Stucky
yeah
or you can run them as a runtime switch
and do it right time right so so I don't
know if there's something really really
specific that you can only do in runtime
yes so I I actually I'm so here are all
the patterns that are so most of lose
all those pattern can only be tacked it
attacked a dynamically because if you
want to be tags statically in JavaScript
it's very hard it is hardly arises yeah
this property specification itself the
code batter itself it's the same whether
if you whether you do it SETI curly or
dynamically yes right right okay
ah yes so so here is the example of our
our formalized the wrong hand patent and
I won't jump into more details here
because we have limited time and so
here's one of the box that we found
three years ago in Hilton's websites it
shows that one day in starting price I
said undefined dollars which is
literally on an exceptional price and so
dealing can pinpoint the exact location
where this undefined working candidate
you this dollar sign so um and here's
another example on a kiosk web page it
shows ads for some items last year's
price is a naughty number and we also
did some empirical study and trying to
compare our dynamic link to with the
existing static link to and so here is
the spectrum it's actually consist of
four like hundreds of lines and each
line shows the percentages for warnings
detected by each two on the specific
website for example uh the green card
shows the percentage of warnings
detected by zgs hint uniquely and the
yellow part means the percentage of
warning interacted by eating uniquely
and black card shows such they are
detected commonly but by Bibles tools
and and as you can see here for some web
sites you can use one linked to to
detect most of the issues but for most
web sites we better use them together so
our conclusion is that static link juice
and that I make things who's like
complement to each other static
no you won't detect all the warnings
there's another issue because um yes
there may be some some these issues we
see static are detecting too but there
are some other issues like for some
warnings like falling over race so
static at two cannot detect this kind of
issue so they just won't
like status a warning because seeing
usually a fever precision over some is
and they just don't show that a warning
and an exact he saw how the dynamic link
to can actually detect that kind of
issue okay so in other problems that we
look at is the performance of JavaScript
because JavaScript uses a cheating time
and CT JIT compiler which is means
just-in-time compilation it's a
combination of an interpreter and the
compiler so what he does he says it
starts off with interpreter and then
based on some profiling information into
collects it may make some aggressive
assumptions and compiles the function
some hot functions into native assembly
codes and the good thing is that it's
greatly improves the performance of Java
code but the bad part is that is make
the performance of Java code very
unpredictable and we invest and we
investigate this kind of issue and we
proposed the term called unfriendly
code which means the piece of Java code
that's very hard for the chaton for for
the jet engines to profit or
optimization so the key idea here is
like in Java code in JavaScript you can
write code in many ways to achieve the
same goal
Wow and however if you write your code
in some way it may be harder for the jet
engine - like optimize that part of the
code so but if you're writing in another
way it may be a lot of faster and here
I'll give you one example suppose you
initialize an empty array and you won't
you like inserts like 10,000 values in
terms of the rate with value I at index
I you there are two ways you can do this
you can either initialize the array from
higher index to lower index or you can
initialize the array from lower index to
higher index and on this way it's about
10 times the words and this way
sorry oh yeah I'll cover last part a
little bit later but let me firstly
explain how what's going on here so if
you're on Rosa
si si a loop thing becomes a little bit
more obvious because so ah what happens
is that at first so what happens is that
if you initialize the array from hiring
next to lower index at first you just
created an empty ring so all of a sudden
you start assigning values at a very
high index letting the same sign value
choose the lower index so the first half
of the iteration featured engines saw
that you creates a very sparse array
they're following orders save memory
you know therefore in order to save
memory see cheat engine will actually um
converts the array to a hash table
inside the jet engine and later on when
when when says that you are actually
creating in down sparser II will
actually converge that sparse array into
a contiguous memory space so that goes
back and forth and actually we still all
the time and also accessing a hash table
as much stores and accessing an aviary
and so we investigate some of the
cheetah friendly capacities in
JavaScript and based on solanki we
develop the to coach it
prov which is a profiling for detecting
jet unfriendly coding javascript so what
essentially Jill probe does is that it
receives the wrong humming events from
Geelong key and these independently
simulates what's going on inside the jet
engine for example here if it sees that
you're creating very sparse array and
you are accessing two very frequently
saying we're just issue a warning how
you were the array was created in words
you say
efficient access pattern haven't seen
the source code location so so based on
our jet 12 - we actually experiment some
found some benchmarks like tens
benchmark or some spider benchmark and
we found a lot of which it unfriendly
code patterns in those benchmarks as
well right and by fixing those Jaedong
friend echo patterns usually just by
swapping two lines of code or just
modifying one line of code in the
benchmark we can improve the performance
by 1% to 26% and do and those
improvements are statistically
significant so here's one so here's
another one Jaedong for a new coat
patterns that we found in real world
program so here we have a tree data
structure so what happens is that in the
tree data structures are about tens of
thousands of nodes and for each nodes
they are constructed by this constructor
function however based on different
conditions the constructor may
initialize C know the property sing
different order like in this damn branch
anymore first initialize these two left
prophets I mean we initialize this right
property in the else branch to the order
is reversed and if we just swap these
two lines of codes and we get 15%
performance improvement on Chrome and
about 3.5 percent performance increments
on Firefox
so it's essentially related to a thing
called inline caching and hidden classes
seems a jet engine so I won't expand
more technical details here because this
party self can be expanded into I kill
one our talk and actually about two
months ago the child core team had also
had an internal talk about this part and
in travel core this hidden class is
called the types or stuff like that and
it's also called Maps or hidden classes
invades engine so what's happening here
is that the original codes are the
original constructor may create objects
of two different kinds of memory layouts
in memory like if you need to enter this
stem ranch then this is what the object
will look like inside the memory the
left property will have a lower offset
and the right property will have higher
offset and if we enter this else branch
then this red property will have a
higher or have higher offsets while
these left up our table will have a
lower offset and this is left of hope
they will have a higher offset and when
your and when all those objects flows
like to one position and we are trying
to retrieve the left the property found
that note object the JIT compiler
may get confused because the laughter
probably can be easy I'm either in the
lower offset or in a higher offset so
the jet engine cannot do some aggressive
assumption assuming that see laughter
properties always seems a fixed location
therefore every time when it tries to
retrieve the property frontal object
always have to do a dynamic look up to
find the Proteas location inside the
solid object
ah and if we swap these two lines each
operation now we can't decipher those
patterns on our neck is what we did is
that we invested and in June most of the
major jet engines and try to summarize
some of the jet on finding Co patterns
in in those engines since then we just
formalized them by ourselves since then
incorporating to Z JavaScript engine but
there is some way to do that for example
in Mozilla and actually Mozilla had it
has its own to coach it coach which is
almost doing the same as to what we did
but we did it first because in their
webpage they also show our two as well
so what jet coach is is essentially
doing in such because the Mozilla has
its own Firefox the SpiderMonkey engines
what they do is that they try to see if
there's any D optimization in their jet
engine and then they try to see are
those the optimization happens
frequently it's and they may give some
actionable suggestions for the developer
like how to like modify your code a
little bit like in in that previous
example maybe you can just make the
constructor it creates objects in a more
consistent format or more consistent
layouts and hopefully you can improve
the performance of your JavaScript
program and yeah so this is one way to
do that like it you can dive deeper into
the jet engine and see
were the key optimisation happens and
then flexes the optimization operation
for the hidden class in the inline
caching on I think all engine is doing
so kind of all the optimization and
that's actually hold across all engines
and I and I think for the sparse array
the V engine and travel core and also
the SpiderMonkey engine are also doing
the same thing so yeah so we are yes
right overall how many optimization like
that are in the modern jet engines for
JavaScript compared to let's say the
optimization that uh that are even CMS C
compiler for instance is basically is
the same complexity or are they simpler
or more complex so I think the GRT
optimization the jet engine is a very
different from z head over time
optimization because in JIT compilation
happens at runtime so what you are
trying to do is to try to save to reduce
the compiler time as much as possible so
they were actually not used some of the
advanced like a static analysis or years
ago JCC that work of nice is pattern and
automatically cannot fix the problem and
then this is just basically the the
JavaScript world catching up with step
by step with something trying to do it
at runtime or no this is basically
something if you couldn't wrote this
programming see for instance and highest
optimization in GCC or whatever and you
still visit open problem or it's the
problem has been solved 20 years ago
that you're catching up here with yeah
so go pushing so in a statically typed
language this issue shouldn't exist
because for each one
the objects they're like tight their
cost structure is already determines
before execution so the compiler can
just grabs your classes structure
without actually dynamically lookups the
property's location these you can just
look up see class structure all the
other objects is then simulate perhaps
accurate mean okay yeah yes because
[Music]
instead of languages you already have
this class notifying if you were to come
fire basically the amount of code let's
say that deal with all these
optimization is it like comparable to
what let's say a modern static for
comparators with all the optimization
for like a statically typed language or
is it an order and I need more or less
what I mean so it's kind of so I I so
personally i so honestly I don't know
how many like tightens the optimization
order in the static complex select n
there's now that give you a number so I
think no question right so how many
optimization are there to to optimize
try to occupies like during your
placement or something like that all the
classical optimizations are index ESC
and copy prop and things like that yes
but there are some optimizations that
are purely based on the dynamic nature
so let's say optimizing type or caching
some lot of things which are different
in nature they we can take compare the
optimization do not say
this is very complex yeah yeah this is
complex because you don't know anything
like you can change the prototype of
object on the runtime thank you
so in the next part of my presentation
I'll briefly summarize the sum of type
so some of the projects that I did in
Microsoft Research and so this is a
project is called a sync track and I've
already gave a very detailed talk about
these parts on in my end of a internship
talk two years ago and you can actually
search no GEOSS all just just search my
name on ResNet you'll be able to to see
more technical details about that
project I'll just summarize on back in
2016 on we we developed a - we started
off off of projects that tries to keep
track of for asynchronous contacts
seeing nodejs applications
so what happens is that thing no Jesus
there are lots of asynchronous operation
like you can register a callback and
after the operating system has done some
things and you will cause a callback to
notify you that the event is been
completed but the problem is when the
callbacks is being invoked the functions
that registers are callbacks ha has all
been popped out from the stack trace so
there's no way for you to like to debug
or trace back to the location where that
a callback was registered so we tried to
implement the instrumentation frame was
a keeps track of these async on taxing
no GS and so that freedom has been
integrated into our glimpsed phone
odious which is for stag diagnostic -
for no GS developed by Microsoft and we
fixed and because initially we just keep
track of all asynchronous events in
noches then we just go a little bit
further to keep track of all synchronous
events in noches so right now that means
we can keep track of all interactions
between the node.js application and the
underlying operating system so that
means we have a sandbox and we extended
that sandbox for no J's security
research um and we found about 300
security vulnerabilities and this as the
title of my talk two years ago is called
tracing and understanding acing costing
know Jesus so this is the overview of
the noches architecture and on the top
level there is no justification and no
justification always needs to use some
of the underlying library provides by
the node.js runtime so for example if
you won't read the fire system you
always have to like first require a far
system package as a fire system
packaging contains some building system
functions that allow you to have access
to the underlying operating systems file
system and there are many other like
packages like that and those standard
library functions are essentially just
to cheer a JavaScript antlion offering
system call and they are translated
through this no gist binding layer which
translates the jobs to call juicy Cosco
and on then under that's then you have
the JavaScript engine can have a door
choco core you can have even loop thread
pour and sink or a sink iOS provided by
the operating system so what we did
these ads we hijack all of the
communications between the noches
application and the underlying
JavaScript engine on by modifying either
a Java standard library or the bonding
layer and also to dynamic
instrumentation and so after a hijacking
all of the communication between the
upper node.js patient and the underlying
offering system we can intercept those
system costs and like enforce some
security policies and based on that we
can dynamically check some of the
security issues on in ogs and we also
verify that as the no bonding layer that
all of the communication are essentially
are actually being hijacked to by our
instrumentation code so the key idea of
the instrumentation it'll is a little
bit different from the source to source
translation so the problem is that's in
JavaScript or in odious once you have a
system call the system call can return
and objects that contains another system
call and thus and that system call can't
have an asynchronous function that takes
a call back and we're not a call back
see is being invoked in a passing other
objects without
system calls so it's not just a simply
wrapping all of the building api's
because if that API returns an object
that contains other API sand that may be
missed so our approach is that we
increments our instrumentation Fremont
like a virus in the memory space of java
code so whenever there is a building on
JavaScript library objects is being
required its first being hijacked it's
and being infected or wrapped by our
installation framework then when that is
when that infected system API further
returns in other objects that's also
being recursively in fact it all wrapped
by our code so in that case all of the
codes as being descendants the children
of C building system objects are all
wrapped recursively and when the Java
code tries to use like those in fact the
objects or functions to make a system
calls and they will be monitored by our
instrumentation code so that's a key
idea but there are also of other tricks
and also other things that we need to
handle like how do you handle the
asynchronous calls to how to handle the
callback and those part I won't cover
it's more details here because they are
already covered in Z and the internship
talk so our instrumentation framework
provides this kind of API is like a
callback is being registered callbacks
is being invoked a synchronous system
how it's being called what's there wrong
hand value what's your arguments what's
your registration context and what's
their callback invocation context and
stuff like that and by overriding those
callbacks you can do a lot of other
interesting stuff
so one thing we look at is this is a
security issue in noches so currently
there are about over 500,000 NPM
packages right now and they are also
there still increasing very rapidly
however on NPM doesn't actually enforce
any like security checking or manual
inspection or manual review process so
anyone can just publish a malware NPM
and anyone can download
very easily so there are currently two
companies there are maybe other
companies but there are two major
companies winding is called no security
platform in otherwise cost nicaya's that
are dedicated to no dia security so what
they did is that so what they are doing
is that they are they have a steam
security expert they manually inspect
the NPM packages yeah and they also
collect all kinds of vulnerability
reports on github and they collect those
vulnerabilities and compile them into
their database and the make of that and
then they will make a tool like to check
some mattifier of the NPM package and
see if packages dependencies and its
dependencies dependencies are any
vulnerable packages in their database by
just matching the path the packaging
name and their version but we think this
approach is not scalable and so we use
our nose sandbox to dynamically check
about 330,000 NPM packages and we found
about 219 tooth security vulnerabilities
and we're still in the process of
reporting those vulnerabilities to those
companies and so far we have already 150
confirmed and 120 are considered highly
severe and those two companies
collectively have about 600 security
vulnerabilities so a quadruped serve
vulnerabilities are reported to by us so
people so there are many different ways
to report the ease are just uh actively
look up like security vulnerabilities on
key fobs NZ just the composite mean
trees are database by themselves or
there are other people like me who
reported to them as well but this is
that one person could say 600 or yeah a
large collection of things yeah so so
they're essentially using crowdsourcing
to like finding security vulnerabilities
because that's how they gives security
assessment yeah yeah they have very
small base if you have 500,000 stuff and
you have only sick I mean 600 or not 750
now so so it works like this for you for
example in favor Indian packages and may
depends on other 20 packages so 20
package to me recursively depends on
like hundreds of other packages so it's
actually called dependency hell when you
write a package like I think someone did
any investigation about say if you
implement some functionality and
publishes a packaging MPM only like 5%
of the code is actually written by the
developer other like 95% are all coming
from those dependencies and because of
this dependency see how any package you
may accidentally required any other like
package it developed by 8 pi is some
malicious use users or other people who
are not very careful with their codes to
me actually introduced the vulnerability
into their code so he's actually a kind
of a serious issue in NPM on yeah this
is one of the most malicious packages
that we found if you just install it and
I'm p.m. hacker you will change your
background of your computer into
nakeds david hasselhoff and another
example for security vulnerabilities is
the directory traversal so we found
about 220 packages having this issue so
directory traversal means that whenever
a packet tries to set up an HTTP server
and then the war server and when the
clients tries to request a file from the
server if the author is is not very
careful
he or she may just concatenates use the
request URI always a base on e I arts
and just to read the file and streaming
it out to the remote client that's
vulnerable to this kind of attack
because
attacker can just use this URL like
daughter / daughter / to request any
file all sides of the route to working
directory and there are lots of other
variants of this kind of attacking URI
off so it's really hard to defend
against these kind of things and even
worse all this directory traversal
vulnerabilities can be fully exploited
to perform
I'm service attack but just requesting
this def zero file which is Linux
virtual files that provides unlimited
streaming to zeros and if you read a
file on the server's ending which is the
leads to the consumption of all memory
or leads to consumption office and
network bandwidth which is essentially
causing Kinari service attack so what I
mean by hash so somebody can just like
sending multiple entries that will go
into the same key that will map to same
key in the hash table and you would have
make a long chain and it would be denied
with also use attack I see artists like
is this tool able to find those kind of
scenarios double more like v8 specific
but it was like so I'm not sure anything
detecting that kind of vulnerability can
be matched can be manifested as like a
random pattern between the node.js
application and the underlying operating
system it can be like formalized as just
a single pattern of the system call from
the notification to the underlying
operating systems and it can be detected
by this kind of tool there are many
other like interesting malicious
packages or security vulnerabilities
that we found the NPM um like we also
found a warm in MPM so what it happens
is that if you install the package you
will self replicate and publish self on
the NPM again and well as we also have
some on pranked NPM packages like
Rockstar
what happens if you install that package
yeah he will use the victim's NPM
account to give yourself a star on NPM
so we also found some somehow he just
wants you in stores I've hack it will
overrides some of the other packages on
your computer we also found some
packages of hackers that are having some
privacy issues like every time we
install that package she will collect
some of your data on computer and send
it to Google Analytics or send it to
it's on private server and for some
packages every time we use it what you
will collect your machines information
send it to a remote private server and
stuff like that yeah we reported our
abilities to sneak I OC send me cards
and then we report and another bunch of
them they send me another card and
t-shirt and this second Z and this
instrumentation Freeman also enables
other kinds of applications for example
because you can keep track of for
asynchronous events in odious you can
actually visualize them and will help
debugging or how program understanding
and stuff like that it's also helping
GED to like for better time travel and
debugging because when you are in a
callback function in the time traveling
debugger oftentimes you want to jump
back to the position where the Quebec
was registered instead of jumping back
to the exact functions that's being
executed before that the callback
function was being executed and it can
be also be used to detect security
issues or this so maybe you can also
increments like container inside no
Jesus because you're essentially
hijacking all the interaction images and
the underlying operating system you can
like implements a some sort of container
ization just for no Diaz those are just
a few examples and for the last part of
my presentation I actually want to focus
a little more on the projects that I've
been working on before I started my PhD
so I was working on applying machine
learning techniques to solve some of the
software hearing problems specifically
like photo localization DPAC prediction
predicting bug fixing time so but in
summary what they essentially are what I
was doing it's actually um either
cleaning the data for like efactor
addiction or fertilization each one is a
problem is like a prediction problem and
so what we did is that you can either
measure anonymity factor for noisy data
in give a prediction because oftentimes
when we collect some data from the soft
engineering projects or maybe
because a human is making making
mistakes all the time and the collected
data may be noisy and we measure the
effectiveness of those see the negative
effect of those noise is in those data
set choose a prediction result and we
also worked on some projects like try to
reduce the human to work on some
projects or tries to eliminate the noisy
data in those data sets and try to
improve the prediction accuracy we also
try to like reduce the redundancy in
training data while still preserving the
prediction accuracy and stuff like that
and because we worked on this project a
little bit earlier back in 2011 and 12
so we actually did a lot of a feature
engineering work and the means of and in
covering domain-specific knowledge into
the training data is likely essentially
adding more information to the
prediction model so they can have better
prediction results or even changing the
machine learning process like originally
it's doing much processing and then we
incorporated some simple feedback to the
loop so that we can incorporate more
information to for better prediction
however I actually don't want to focus
on those part because um there are
actually some of the more important
lessons of it's that I've learned from
doing this kind of research so to show
you one one example this is the
technique called photo localization so
what these are trying to do is that if
you have a program and may contain some
bugs and and you have the set of test
cases and we run the program on the set
of test cases some of the test case will
pass some of the test case will fail and
so the cross strings can automatically
learn orco ok automatically are do some
inference and find out the back
locations these are the program so so to
the approach that we worked on is called
statistic of baka localization it's
actually first attracting the profiling
information like a coverage information
for each one of the statement in each
test coverage in each test cases then we
also gather the test outcome as the
Labour put it right here
and then we use some techniques to try
to like predict so or infer the probable
park location inside the program and
actually back in 2009 people in that
research area are already started using
urine I was to like predict so where the
bucket is probably inside a program so
the first use the neural a go to like
based on this our coverage information
and this labor which is test the Passat
has a failed she tries to predict the
testing outcome and when they learned
that neural networks and they just do
some feature selection and see which
like statements on it is the most
influential effector tool to make the
predictor predicts that this output is
fail or pass no there are there are two
different kinds of prediction technique
swine's called single buck buck
localization and another one just the
students as your mom multiple bucks in
the coach
no no but pieces are so so the so let me
see so so the training shows are exactly
examples that I just mentioned are the
Trinity that I just checked so it just
looks like this each instance is the
coverage information and each a labor of
that instance is just the test outcome
and then Z just the first Oscars machine
learning detector to first a predict
accurately see test outcome since he
tries to take a look at the machine
learning model and try to find out which
like statements or which feature is the
most of influential effects leading to
make such predictor to believe that this
should be a failed a test case yeah so
but um but a lot of people have taken
take a look has a lot of different kinds
of machine learning techniques they also
even use decision tree which is even
easier for you to like to find out which
line through code is mostly influential
for for predicts and test the outcome um
yes
so you mentioned that no you can look at
the model to see which part of the model
is making the prediction that will pass
or fail how would you do this or let's
say you know networks where the models
might be quite intricate yeah yeah yeah
III think he's not papers they have some
heuristics on - um but I don't remember
actually it's the technical details
because we actually don't work on that
kind of technique it's uh Lee how how
how actually show you that that's so
that kind of machine learning techniques
is it's not very accurate in this kind
of problem and because a more simplest
statistic model is actually more
effective for this kind of approach but
later I are actually tell you such this
even this kind of approach is not
practical and I'll show you some of the
lessons that I learned why this kind of
approach is not actually practical for
real-world usage so people have learned
over time so so like this is actually
called a spectrum based of optimization
I think it was a kind of quite hard
research area like ten years ago and I
think maybe more than hundreds of papers
are publishing software sharing
conferences for without research area
and like different kinds so different
people propose the different kind of
techniques to tackle is suspicious score
of a statements in the program and they
try to rank see statements based on
their suspicions it's nice and then the
just expects the developers who like
inspect see pocky location one by one
and hopefully easy can't find out or the
hopefully this technique can help them
find out the back location so so one of
the most effective techniques is
actually the simplest one so the key
idea is that see use this formula for
each one of the statement to calculate
the suspicious score independently so
this formula is actually quite easy on
the enumerator are it's just the
constant number of failure traces that
are covering that current a statement
well on the denominator is just the
number of failing traces and the number
of fortresses are covering us so the
basic intuition is that if a stay to me
so if a statement is covered
in failing test cases were covered
Lessing passing test cases science more
likely to contains a bug yes so it's a
very simple idea right and usually on
some small benchmarks or even on some
medium programs it can often ranks the
actual back location like in the top 1%
of the rent lease with respected to all
of these statements in the program yeah
and I actually I I also have a demo for
that it it's actually based on Jelani as
well so because the Howard language is
an instrumentation framework you can do
a lot of things based on that so I just
implement that in Gilani as well suppose
that and this is actually a simple
application for mooc like students can
submit some references can submit some
party solutions and the instructor can
upload the reference implementation then
our system then just randomly generated
a bunch of test cases and then runs on
the reference implementation i guess he
cracked the test outcome then we just
rerun those test cases on the pocky
implementation and saying we also gets a
the test outcome and then we just
compare their testicle all come to
decide whether and all test cases
passing or failing and then based on
that simple formula we can calculate the
possible park location for example if I
just want sudden you will flag all the
ah potential bug locations in the codes
and if it's more likely to be a bugs and
will have a darker background color so
here it shows that I this demon contains
a bug and actually a seeded debug and if
I just to fix it and I ruined again
saying you will show no more tests and
no no no more failing test cases and
every statement his consider is a clean
is this actually are not the techniques
that are published long time ago but sir
but our techniques was was trying to
improve this kind of technique so this
kind of ranking technique say is this is
actually based on very ancient like a
statistical Park localization technique
it's just such a very simple formula
that I showed right here Oh so sigh our
contribution here is so one project that
we did is try to reduce the number of
training leaders that are needed by this
kind of prediction model and then while
still preserving is accuracy so so in
other things that we did was sad because
this technique just is doing batch
process right so you just give you the
programs and we'll run all the test
cases and then you need to give you a
rank without actually asking for any
feedback from the developers while we
found such areas is a simple way to
incorporate the feedback which means
when the developer is reading see
Stillman from top to to bottom so
sometimes he may be sure that this
diamond is clean or he may be sure that
this statement is buggy then we can
incorporate that feedback into the photo
realization processes and improves the
fertilization accuracy but that is not
my main point here so so we so that was
the risk yeah because this research area
was a very hot research area but almost
but but sometimes later people have
realized that these techniques say it's
actually not yet a practical for
real-world usage and we actually um so
after I actually spend one you're doing
research you're trying to improve try to
improve the performance of this kind of
system on like benchmarks or
medium-sized applications I finally try
to work to make it work on like large
applications like Firefox which contains
millions of lines of code that I
realized as this is technique it's
actually not practical yet because for
one of the reason is that when you're
working we are applying these techniques
like Firefox if there are 1 million
lines of code and if the buggy code is
ranked in the top like 1% the developers
still has to like inspect tens of
thousands of lines of code which is
actually not practical and also people
have learned over time or either to
improve a study to find out that
oftentimes when you show a buggy line to
a developer without giving them any
logical explanation let me just
gets confused and then they may just
miss that back even if you actually
always shows the back in the top
resulting the ranking result and an
another bigger issue that we found that
people have found over time is that
false positives can is two very radical
interests the job off like if the
developer like inspects like top five
results and they still can't find any of
the bugs and even just fall back to
their old way of doing things like
setting a breakpoint and do manual
debugging stuff like that and let's just
generalize that a little bit to some of
the challenges for applying machine
learning to program languages soft
engineering problems and so one of the
bigger challenging for first of all
suppose an area is that usually when you
try to use machine learning to predict
something in the software engineering
project though so usually this problem
actually requires very high accuracy
because in that area there often an
alternative exists like for the photo
ization developer can always use manual
debugging or there are always other kind
of things that they can do to find to
the crazy bug and if the accuracy is not
high enough then people just get boring
or do just to get disappointed and they
were just a fallback so they're all way
of doing things and and also on this
kind of if we try to use machine
learning to like it generally something
from the soft engineering project or
predict something for source office
during projects usually it's actually
project is specific i want to pretty
something just about our project or
unless that's a very large open source
project oh that's very large commercial
projects that involves a lot of the
human interactions there won't be a lot
of labor data available for machine
learning so that's another bigger issue
so another issue is that unless the
machine learning model is fully
automated and it's actually a needs
extra and these accuracy is very high
the entire process always have to
involve humans in the loop which means
that when it generates some results it
has to
ask humans to inspect the results and
then ask humans to incorporate that
result into the real world the real
world product and so if the machine
learning project can only give like a
logical explanation or makes the results
are understandable for the two
developers and then maybe very hard to
apply that kind of a technology like two
to real-world production so
maintainability it's like also another
bigger issue even for program synthesis
I believe you generate a piece of codes
and if it's too too hard to read and
developer cannot understand that once
there's the bodies it will be very hard
to fix you know so so this is my last
slides summarizing some of the future
interests so I'm mostly interested in
these are working on JavaScript to
change support or on using all kinds of
techniques to improve the reliability
performance and security of software
systems and and also software system
definitely including is definitely
including machine learning systems and
I'm also very interested in making this
dynamic analysis research all free most
a little bit more sophisticated because
oftentimes we see a very high runtime
overhead in the installation techniques
so if we can just like integrate this
instrumentation Freeman coach or angry
or async track directly into the engine
I will hopefully achieve a better
performance and could reduce the wrong
time overhead so another thing that
emerges the English program synthesis
because so problem synthesis
so essentially original in the original
way developer I like writing software by
themselves that's in machine learning
people's term that's like an expert
system right you give the specification
either in terms of formal specification
or you give specification in terms of
the input output examples then the
expert are just the customers and
developers then based on those input
outputs
since they just developed extra
that use a rule-based system - like maps
the input to the output but right now
it's interesting to say that the program
synthesis can just search for programs
under generates the output and I'm
actually most interesting like speeding
up the searching process to like reduce
the see the searching time because I
feel that scalability could be a bigger
issue for program synthesis field
because the larger and larger the
program you want the synthesis all more
expressive the language you are trying
to use then it seems that the search
space would be much larger so be
interesting to use some heuristics or
some other techniques like reduce the
searching space to further speed up the
process and finally I want to thank some
of my collaborators either in Microsoft
Research or in Berkeley and in other
organizations so I and I also want to
thank the following organizations and
Institute for funding my research um so
yeah that's it thank you very much
[Applause]